[Music]
from the studio still nursing their
post-end game
hangover comes an epic team up between
the fourth lead in W division the least
watch Disney plus hero and the amnesiac
who always says some place better to be
where the hell have you been all this
time there are a lot of other planets in
the universe I was going to come back
there was people that needed me I'm so
sorry I have to deal with this she she
does this a lot kind of makes you miss
the old days older older older we really
could have just stopped there
huh the
maral you told yourself you wouldn't see
another MCU film I can't and wow you
weren't kidding this time because now
that it cost around 200 bucks a year to
stay current with about three movies and
three shows annually some of which are
the worst things to happen to I since
bleach how could you not hop off at this
point even the characters skip the
streaming shows when did you get powers
why did you get that my grandma so I
switched with someone named Kamala Khan
yeah she seem to be as confused as you
are like the MCU itself watch Carol
daners get weighed down by Disney plus
baggage the anate Is Here Yeah well she
was and then these two just sort of
appeared she's still so strong her
fights are a
formality still struggling to remember
what happened in Captain Marvel see
flashes and still letting that trademark
Charisma shine need a
hand yeah I didn't want this
still yeah but now for the first time
since Scott Pilgrim free Larson gets to
sing and dance give me a chance here
before it
[Music]
as long as you don't count the 2018 film
bosotti
Blues this can't be real we're sending
you to India me it is I am just a
fool is the con family okay with this oh
no no no no rounding out the brome is
Monica Rambo whose powers and problems
come from fondling mysterious glowing
barriers
stop fondling the barriers and carrying
the movie on her back is Kamala Khan the
last teenager who still gets hyped for
the
stuff Iman volani gives her all as the
top contributor to Captain Marvel
section on Archive of her own hold that
thought but that love will be tested
when she sees her hero leave refugees to
die come now we need to save who we can
almost gets her killed incoming missile
we need to leave now I can do this and
you'll kill us trying and admits to some
light genocide I'm the reason why the
Civil War started in the first place I'm
the reason why they couldn't breathe the
air that's how I got the name
Annihilator just kidding besties always
hold space for their Queens to slay I'm
glad to be
here entire
planets that's going to be really tough
to
Doodle secret Invasion left Nick Fury a
broken man but that show will get memory
hold like Hulk son the Inhumans and the
fact that Earth is a giant egg besides
the whole scroll Refugee crisis gets
offed with a phone
call bad
flashback now Furies become jokey Jeff
Bezos pulling randoms into space your
dad is not adjusting very well to space
travel and abusing his employees much
easier to transport a family of cats
than hundreds of crew members but if
you're wondering where his wife went why
scrolls are welcome on Earth we will
kill every last one of you or how Carol
feels about him secretly harvesting her
DNA don't overthink it or he's a scroll
too or black girl magic black girl
magic so gear up for another phase five
dud that despite the online hate is at
its best when it's just having fun for
girls complete with Disney princess
makeovers kitties and using emotional
intelligence to work through differences
thank you Iron Man could never
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you it say that there isn't
enough COPE in the world to Huff before
Sky beams look cool again name jokes get
funny again Firefly NightLight Countess
Marvel mistress Marvel Dr Marvel Lady of
Light frequency no Pulsar no Pulsar
light lady absolutely not we'll Workshop
it no thank you or in credit cameos feel
surprising again you somehow crossed
through a tear in SpaceTime if they
really want to sell a crossover we
should tell them about the money plane
initiative whatever you want to wager on
the money plane as you covered want to
bet on Spider-Man alligator Secret
Wars starring the board identity Rambo
first dud con you dig it Patch Adams
soulmates the singing planet is all dead
now right the plot of Space Balls I
would hate for your people to suffocate
when I strip the atmosphere commence
operation vac you suck
suck suck suck proof this was written by
AI why are hands so hard to draw kitten
in the streets hentai in the sheets and
take a shot anytime someone says jump
Point jump Point jump Point jump Point
jump Point jump Point jump Point jump
Point jump Point jump Point jump
point The Marvelous m space
holes all right the villain let's see
big hammer makes his dumb face a lot
dies never to be seen again classic
MCU this is a pen this is a
pen the laws of physics cease to exist
on your
stove Pomeranians are a small but hearty
breed stop showing
spiders